ils prétendent que le monde est plus sûr
aujourd'hui classe qu'il ne l'a jamais
été dans l'histoire de notre
civilisation
vous vous vous sentez plus en sécurité
en tout cas moi non
le monde a changé la guerre que nous
menons actuellement
exige un nouveau genre de soldats
il faut les hommes avec les aptitudes et
la rage nécessaire
pour affronter des menaces que nous
envisageons même pas
il nous faut quelqu'un qui peut plonger
dans une tornade et en ressortir comme
s'il ne s'agissait que d'une vulgaire
petit prix si vous vouliez que je
revienne suffisait de me le demander au
clair des fours cd
mais ayez l'air cool quand vous le
faites
je sens je vais m'éclater
des flingues des filles
une domination mondiale
zander kate je reviens
u 17 du chiffre
les africains de soja
winnipeg
moi
finissons en avec moi quand warner
dans cette lettre
ça peut pas la folie
chaque semaine
charlotte au pays tourne
a coubertin mais dawn
gorman